there's no turning back now right
everything is coming to a head things
solutions exist and changes happening
for quicker than ever has done before
Megan Merkel and Prince Harry are
opening up about the black lives matter
movement the black lives matters
movement
matters to Megan and it matters to Harry
and I understand that this is going to
be an area where we're going to see the
couple of doing a lot more work and
taking a lot more interest this changes
neatly demons coming last week the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex participated in a
video call on behalf of the Queen's
Commonwealth Trust of which bTW they are
president and vice president
respectively to talk all about the fight
for racial equality with youth leaders
we can deny educators to see the world
differently however once you start to
realize that there is that bias there
then you need to acknowledge it you need
to acknowledge it but then you need to
do the work to be able to become more
aware they come in on this from
different perspectives Megan is a
Californian Harry is it as an English
man and both of them keeping abreast of
what's happening both here in the UK and
in LA this is something they want to be
more involved with and I'm told we're
going to see them really focusing their
energy on this over the next coming
weeks during the call Megan called the
current movement a moment of reckoning
adding that racism exists not only in
the big moments but also in the quiet
ones the nuances that I think it makes
it confusing for a lot of people to
understand the role that they play in
that either passively or actively but I
think even more so passively it's not
enough to just be a bystander than
saying what wasn't me the messages echo
Megan's recent graduation speech to her
alma mater in Los Angeles with this
diverse and vibrant and open-minded as I
know the teachings and immaculate heart
are I know you know that black lives
matter the 38 year old mom of one said
that knowing when to lead versus when to
listen are the two key ingredients
for meaningful change and Harry he
agreed adding that we need to learn from
past mistakes there's no way we can move
forward unless we acknowledge it the
post it's not gonna be easy and in some
cases is not going to be comfortable but
he needs to be done because guess what
everybody benefits
Megan reiterated her hubby sentiment
saying that growing pains are painful
this process is painful and it has been
for a long time but through that immense
pain what we can have tremendous faith
in is knowing if there will be growth
and that's what we're seeing happen
every single day the convo took place on
what would have been Harry's mom
Princess Diana's 59th birthday that same
day the 35 year old royal appeared in a
video on the Dianna Awards Instagram
page honoring the six recipients of this
year's award has been an inspiration to
many of you I like to assure you she
would be in the clip Harry assured fans
that his mom would have been a major
supporter of the black lives matter
movement like many of you she never took
the comfortable but she stood for
something and she stood up for people
who needed
[Music]